Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Riddle School.
Now this game is an oddity.
And I have to explain why.
A lot of you guys have been recommending this game
so I had to look it up, and I found out that
this game first came out on Newgrounds
10 years ago and that may not seem
amazing, but ten years ago was my primary
time for trolling around Newgrounds and
playing all the games. And the thing is
this is a very popular game on Newgrounds, and I've never heard of it
I've never even seen it. I've never
played a single game and there's like
eight games in the series.
Admittedly they came out over time but
why didn't I find out about it? So I had
to look up the developer and his name is
JonBro on Newgrounds but in
Newgrounds on a post he made he said he's
no longer going by the name of JonBro
he's going by the name of "Jonochrome"
so that name sounded familiar
and here's why; when I looked up Jonochrome, I found out that he is the
developer of One Night At Flumpty's! Which
is by far my favorite fan game of
Five Nights at Freddy's so it's a weird
circle of events that really is not
really coincidence
it's- it's just spawned from a neato
idea thinghyhyhy
You know, a factoid!
A FACULOID!
Fuck it..
Let's play the game, anyway.
Okay! Whoaah.
Wait that's- that's the Madness
soundtrack is that a reference to that
when it says Mathness because that's
that's Madness music I definitely know
that from the Madness games if you don't
know about the Madness
Uhh...
Flash animations not games go look them up
they're on Newgrounds they're all
amazing if you like bloody (* fingerbanging*) violent gory
stick figure type people blasting each
other with guns
you might want to check out a lot of
cool flash movies about that one.
But anyway!
grueeAAAAAAAAAAAAAH
I've been sitting here for two hours straight listening to "addition facts"
facts all because I teach somebody, I'm in a
special class
I don't even have a smart teacher! Right now I'm as free as a bird in a bird cage.
all right that's it I'm getting out of
the school. What's 131+42 again? I forget.
Uh, a hundred seventy-three?
UUGGGHHHH
Oh god, he died
Oh well
"Riddle School"
Yeah...
Oh-oh ok I guess we're playing now. Hello. South "The teacher may be- not be smart but
he knows when I opened that door".
Oh. "No outlet here. You can tell the
school's low-budget just by looking at that."
Ok, all right then. "That's it!" What's it? "Hey teacher can I sharpen my pencil?"
"Only one person at a time!" Wow you are a
bright person.
Oh. Oh! "Now that was sharp" Oh god is this
gonna be a pun game?
Ughh I make enough puns in the titles of my other games but this is ridiculous
All right. Water fountain, lockers, North.
Ohh! Hi! Oh hey teacher! "This is my teacher Miss
Cophey, who drinks more coffee than anyone else I know.
She finishes teaching
lessons two hours early in a hard to understand jittery voice.
That's Smiley, she's the only one in school who likes
learning.
Smiliey's also [the] one I made fun of to be in that special class.
That's Phred, my best friend and most
board class member.
that's Zack, who's always cold, he has no
problem freezing the water fountain.
Okay! that's probably a clue!
Oh, wow, Feather Buster in a dobla.
That's a drawing
by somebody named JonBro
who's the developer of this game. Okay, so that's probably a clue, because I'm probably
gonna need to freeze that water fountain
for some frickin reason. I have no idea
why. "You don't want to know what's happened here" Mark: I think I do.
North-- Hello(?) Why are you standing in a closet, Bob?? And why is your name tag on
backwards?
"Get out of my closet" Mark: Okay, that's really weird.
Maybe I need to dust off everything-- Oh. Hey
Everything was dusty. That's what I did there. "You found my feather duster! Keep
the change." Mark: Okay.
"Thanks. I've been looking all over the school for this. The playground birds
need dusting."
"Well, I gave you a dollar. Don't waste it on socks." Mark: What?
He's a janitor. He's 5's dad, 808.
Okay. Alrighty then.
Okay. I'm already confused, but here we go.
*Mark reads the graffiti* "I <3 nobody" "5 was not here" "ornj is my fav colr"
Mark: Okay.. "That's the only stall the guys ever use. Mainly for graffiti."
"That's the untouched stall which is in perfect condition and is currently on
display." "As crazy as it sounds, those are sinks. Look at the sleek design!
I would have thought twice about escaping school if it all was that cool-
looking." Mark: Okay. Louise--
"Hey, it's me. Richy, the hall guard .You got a hall pass? 'Cause if you don't, you
can't pass." Mark: Okay, so I need to go find a hall pass.
Maybe Ms. Cophey? Can she give me a hall pass?
Nah? Okay. So now I gotta find a ha-- Ooh!
Hello! Aw, that was convenient! I didn't even mean to click on that! Do the other
lockers have anything in them?
Probably not. *Reads the poster* "5 for Prez" "5 is a popular guy in school. It's because of his "vote 5" shirt."
Oh. I get that reference. Okay, so I got a hall pass..
Yeah, I got a hall pass. Get outta my way.
"Listen, if I went in there, you'd hear screaming and shrieks not only from anyone
in there but from me." Mark: Okay. *Reads the poster* "School has 7 students and more than 50 lockers."
"That's a poster I made because of the bizarre number of lockers." Mark: Okay. Alright,
Oh. Hi. What the hell you doin'? "Oooh... Gimme a cookie..."
I don't have a cookie. I got a dollar-- Woaaah. What happened to him?? Did he dive for it?
What the hell happened? [Nobody will ever know ^q^]
"What are you DOING here?!" Mark: I dunno. What's with this office?
Jeez. *Reads the options* "I need to talk to the principal" "Standing" "What teacher are you?" "Wrong room"
What?
Uh.. What teacher are you?
"That's none of your business! GET OUT!" Okay. Um.. I need to talk to the principal?
"And why is that?"
Um.. I wanna tell him a joke! :D "Oh. Jokes are always fun! Go right in!"
WHAT?! Why is MY weird logic making me progress through this game?!
That doesn't make any SENSE! Ahh, I'll take it, whatever. It's fine by me.
Oh. Hi.
This is definitely madness music. 100%. And I LOVE it.
Hi-- Oh sorry. Hey buddy- Wow. What kind of principal are YOU?
"Nice of you to drop by. Bye then!" Mark: Thanks lady!
You're nice. Okay. So-- Wow. Holy shit. What's this the key to? Is it the key to outside?
Ooh. Eugh. Well hello. "That's Greg. The least hungry and most restful student in this school."
"That's a diagram of this cafeteria." "Cookie vending machine is unfortunately broken."
Can I use anything in here? No? "That's the school famous smiley smudge."
"That's how I made fun of Smiley. With mustard." Mark: Okay. School famous, huh? Alright.
So, we got to get through this door somehow which means that we gotta get stuff to
get through the door, which means that we
need to find something else, but I can't
go THERE.
I've been in the bathroom.. Let's see... So there's gotta be like a locked door.
Oh! YEAH! :D Okay!
Wow. Was that it? Holy crap. It was inspired by Pico's School! Okay, so
I thought it was a little vaguely
familiar and I have played Pico's School--
Okay, if you don't know about Newgrounds, their mascot is a guy by the name of Pico
And they probably still use Pico, today. And then people would like
make animations about it, and the creator
of Newgrounds, Tom Fault would make
animations of Pico. There's a whole ecosystem-- Like, Newgrounds, is it's
own living beast. And, you know, it may
have fallen out of popularity, but it
still holds a very keen place in my
heart and I'm shocked that that's the
end of the game! I don't know if there
was some other secret that I was
supposed to do there?
I mean was the whole point in about the kid freezing the water?
I mean there's a lot more riddle school
games apparently there's like eight of
them in total or something like that and
they all like span periods of time and
i'm curious to play them because I
relate very much to new grounds and all
these like references to different new
ground things that are in here and it's
really cool to see but either way i'll
leave that up to you if you want to see
the other games let me know down in the
comments below I always loved going
through and seeing all the cool news
ground stuff that is out there so thank
you everybody so much for watching
and as always...
I will see YOU...
in the next video!
BUH-BYE!!
(YEAH Oh, PAT ME A MILLION TIMES ON THE BACK!
ow...)
*MARK'S INSANE LAUGHTER*
oh mah gawd